من هلله ه فيها عصب فيها عصب محطه بس طلع
الاصبع بحركه هيك بضله واقف شايف وريه كيف
من ه ورا انحبس تقريبا 23 يوم ضرب عذاب
يشخوا علينا يطلقوا الكلاب علينا وقعدو
على ركبنا من الساعه 5ه الصبح 4 الصبح ل
12 في الليل ممنوع تقيم ركبك على الارض
الميه اللي كنا
نشربها ميه مواسير الميه جنب الحمامات
واله قرف مش طبيعي الضابط يقوللي دصب مرتك
قدامك وخليها تلبسلك قميص والكلام هذا
يعني يحطم
معنوياته حدا شفنا حدا والله مقط مين غ
والله اطلع مكسر 18 يوم مشبوح اعتقلوني من
مدرسه فلسطين الوكاله الاونر اللاجئين
نقلونا وا خذونا على السجن على موقع
البحري انا قعدت تس ايام عريان تسعه ايام
بلياليهن السقعه فيزيكي قتلتني قتل انا
انا ظهري هيني مش عارف انا مكصور مخلو مش
عارف ايش مالي مش قادر اتحرك منه يعني
بدهم كانوا وياني اعترف على شغلات انا
بعرفها و ما اعترفت وظليت ني مشبوح لما
الله افج من عنده حالي على الله الله يفك
اسر اللي ضيين يا رب ان شاء الله
يا تم اعتقالي في من مركز اليرموك ملعب
اليرموك وتقريبا اعتقالي تم 13 يوم وال
تقريبا يعني ضرب وبهدله
واهانه بوكسات وشلاليت وشرحي اعينا ورشوا
علينا ميه
ويغلط علينا كلام بذيء يعني من لحد من يوم
ما اعتقلو واحنا ايدينا مربطين و مغميين
خبزه هقد صغيره ناشفه كل يوم واحده على
الفطور وواحده على الغدا وواحده على
العشاء ناشف يعني وفي بقى معطب نرجعه ما
نرضاش ناكل ايا ما ناكل انا كان معي اللي
هو سكر
اي ايام ما طول النهار ماخذ الابره ماخذ
العلاج كانت طول المده مكلبش الايدين
ومغمى العينين وقاعد على الركب على مده
شهر واللي بقوم عن ركبه بتعلق وشبوه
وممنوع تتحرك واذا واحد قام وقف ووقف
الاكل وقف الحمام كل شي يعني طوابير كان
اعتقلو من حي الزيتون
الساعه 3ه ونص العصر قعدوا مقاعدنا ثلاث
ايام في الصحراء بلا اكل وشرب كنا نطلب
شربه ميه ما رضوا يشربو اخر شي صاروا ايش
يسووا فينا يدونا من الجبات على الارض عن
علي متر ونص وبعد ما هذا ادونا حبوب بنعرف
ايش هي كان بصار يحطو لنا في الميه حبوب
ولا ما بصار كل يوم كنت اعده كسنه من
العذاب اللي كنت اشوفه فيش نام يمكن ساعه
بربها اللي ننام ويجي في نص الليل يصحيه
كل شويه
يصحيه ويكب علينا
ميه